[Musique]
mon invité à siéger pendant trois
mandats à l'assemblée nationale et à
chaque fois aux presses c'était dans les
rangs de l'opposition élu en 2007 sous
les couleurs du ps dans la loire sous
françois hollande il a rejoint les
frondeurs pour finalement quitter le
parti socialiste est à 50 ans il a
décidé de ne pas se représenter bonjour
régis juanico bonjour alors je sais pas
si vous connaissez le concept de
l'émission mais imaginez vous êtes un
peu comme au cinéma vous voyez
l'ambiance ici est le film que vous
allez voir c'est celui des 15 années que
vous avez passé ici à à l'assemblée ce
que vous êtes prêts pour cette dernière
séance oui je suis prêt avec les mots et
je passais parti
alors figurez-vous régis juanico qu'on a
retrouvé les images de vos premiers pas
à l'assemblée nationale en 2007 regardez
ils s'installent pour cinq ans à
l'assemblée nationale dans le parcours
il y à la fameuse remise de la manette
inventaire il ya bien sûr les écharpes
tricolores
dont je pense me servir assez
fréquemment bientôt compter qu'on aura
les premières manifs contre le
gouvernement voilà donc on pourra la
porter
la coop garde
on peut éventuellement utilisés dans
l'est dans les véhicules voilà mais que
moi personnellement je n'utiliserai pas
à vous avez vous n'avez pas trop changé
en quinze ans déjà c'est ce qu'on peut
remarquer non j'ai beaucoup utilisé mon
écharpe il a eu trois donc oui mais la
cocarde exploser avait tenu parole sur
la cocaïne oui exactement j'ai jamais
utilisé ma cocarde je trouve que pas de
passe droit parce qu'on est élu a pas ce
droit vous avec les députés
contrairement à d'autres élus locaux non
non non pas de chauffeur et c'est très
bien comme cela voilà on essaye d'être
comme nos concitoyens dans la vie
quotidienne alors ce que je retiens
aussi c'est cette volonté dès le début
d' aller manifester
je parlais de l'opposant de toujours en
début d'émission il était déjà là oui et
puis là j'arrive s'étendent en 2007
c'est nicolas sarkozy qui va être élu
président de la république on est dans
le clivage l'a vraiment droite-gauche
coin alors sous françois hollande plus
tard vous avez là aussi fini par
rejoindre si l'on peut dire des rangs de
l'opposition puisque en avril 2014 vous
avez signé l'appel des sens qui était un
petit peu l'acte fondateur de ce qu'on a
appelé les frondeurs dans ce texte vous
affirmiez à l'époque que le temps du
parlement est venu et vous vouliez
imposer au gouvernement un contrat de
majorité alors un parlement qui impose
ses lignes au gouvernement c'est
faisable sous la vème république pas du
tout oui effectivement il faudrait une
sixième république il faudra
effectivement un régime qu'ils soient
qui donne beaucoup plus de pouvoir au
parlement mais on estimait que françois
hollande n'était pas fidèle aux
engagements que nous avions pris nous en
étant élu en 2012 selon un programme
politique et donc c'est le vote contre
la loi macron c'est le vote contre la
loi elle connerie et puis c'est la
déchéance de nationalité ou là on est
passé à un cran supérieur donc moi je me
suis pas considéré comme un frondeur je
suis considéré comme une vigie nous est
quand même allé jusqu'à signer une
motion de censure contre le gouvernement
de l'époque
jusqu'à finalement quitté quitter la
majorité ça a été une rupture pour vous
une rupture douloureuse ou oui ça a été
une rupture douloureuse et je dirais
même que à l'époque
dans nos circonscriptions nous le
vivions extrêmement mal parce que nous
sentions effectivement que les électeurs
qui nous avaient élu en 2012 était
extrêmement mécontent de l'orientation
politique du quinquennat et que on le
vivais très mal parce qu'on était pris
en tenaille entre la fidélité qu'on nous
demandait en tant que majorité
présidentielle et puis les engagements
que nous avions pris nous devant nos
électeurs alors pendant ses trois
mandats il ya un fil rouge chez vous
c'est le sport la politique du sport
vous vous les avez produit plusieurs
rapports parlementaires sur ce sur ce
sujet pourquoi le sport tout simplement
parce que c'est le fil rouge de ma vie
même avant la politique je peux pas
faire une semaine sans faire de sport
sans faire une activité physique je
porte le maillot du coquelicot
saint-etienne et je continue a lancé à
50 ans lancé poids de marteau et de
disques blu ray tout à fait tous les
engins lourds voilà parfois ça me coûte
au niveau de mon dos mais voilà mais je
vais y arriver aussi le foot vous êtes
gardien capitaine et sélectionneur de
l'équipe de foot des députés de
l'assemblée est alors figurez vous qu'on
a retrouvé des images d'un match de foot
mémorable c'était l'équipe des députés
face au variétés club de france en 2018
regarder oui l'équipe de l'assemblée
nationale était emmenée par son
capitaine le socialiste le réseau joie
nico
la muraille
il a été intraitable
le dur que l'arrière et s'est passé mais
qui n'a gagné 6 magasins
bon finalement l'équipe de l'assemblée
nationale sa clique 17 à 0
17 but à 0 comme disait baron pierre de
coubertin l'essentiel c'est de
participer oui bon je vous précise pas
c'est qu'en face de nous il ya quand
même des internationaux c'était panama
où la voilà robert pirès mais enfin
beaucoup d'autres alain giresse donc
voilà mais ça reste un bon souvenir
malgré le score final oui et c'était un
moment de respiration aussi puisque nous
avons aussi des députés des femmes dans
notre équipe quatre ou cinq qui
permettait d'avoir tout le monde dans un
moment qui était pas un moment politique
ou de clivage bon dans la rubrique
suivante j'ai deux trois questions à
vous poser alors si vous utilisez la
langue de bois je sort le carton rouge
oui
alors on l'a vu vous avez presque
toujours été dans l'opposition je citais
pierre de coubertin tout à l'heure tu
sais pas si vous connaissez la la suite
de cette citation l'important dans la
vie ce n'est pas le triomphe mais le
combat est ce que ça résume pas un peu
votre parcours politique
oui alors moi j'ai fait le con temps 15
ans j'ai dû faire ici trois mille
interventions en séances en commission
2000 audition à l'occasion des trente
trois rapports parlementaires que j'ai
publié donc si vous voulez au bout de
quinze ans je trouve que ces combats
n'ont pas été vains j'ai fait ce que je
voulais faire je pars sans aucune
frustration et donc par rapport à ça
effectivement oui là l'engagement
politique le mandat d'élu mandat d'élu
nationale mais aussi ancrée sur le
terrain oui c'est un combat permanent
dit aucune frustration mais vos idées
politiques n'ont jamais triomphé pendant
que vous étiez à l'assemblée vous n'avez
jamais siégé dans une majorité qui était
totalement en accord avec vos idées ça
reste pas un regret oui en même temps on
a fait aussi beaucoup de choses entre
2012 et 2017 on a participé à un certain
nombre de réformes de conquêtes sociales
dont moi je peux être fier représentant
de circonscription ouvrière avec un
passé milliers ce qu'on a fait sur la
pénibilité au travail par an pour
acheter pas entièrement le bilan de
françois hollande bien sûr que non bien
sûr qu'ils avaient dû du bilan positif
on ce que j'ai fait sur le sport on m'a
laissé tranquille voilà donc là dessus
j'ai pu faire des avancées importantes
je pense aux sports sur ordonnance en
particulier j'aurais voulu que le budget
du sport qui est passé en quinze ans de
0,22 à 0 33 % du budget la nation soit
plus important mais voilà ce que j'ai
voulu faire notamment dans le domaine du
sport j'ai pu le faire sans aucune
entrave lors de votre dernière question
gouvernement vous avez livré un regard
assez critique sur la façon dont
travaillent les députés à l'assemblée
nationale vous expliquez que le
parlement vote trop de lois mais qu'ils
contrôlent et évalue trop peu est ce que
c'est en partie pour ça que vous avez
décidé de ne pas vous représenter
vous estimez que les députés travaillent
pas dans de bonnes conditions oui il ya
un côté frustrant effectivement 80% du
temps passé à discuter des textes de loi
100 ex par an donc ça fait cinq cents
par mandature alors qu'on ne concerne
que 10 entre 10 et 20% du temps à
contrôler le gouvernement et évaluer les
politiques publiques pour moi sont les
deux fonctions les plus importantes il
est important que légiférer bien sûr on
passe trois mois sur le projet de loi de
finances initiale qu'ils voient
d'intention passe trois heures sur la
loi de règlement qui est pourtant la loi
de vérité budgétaire donc un problème
effectivement allez je vous propose de
prendre un verre pour se détendre un peu
saoulé
dans cette émission on s'intéresse aussi
un peu aux coulisses de la vie à
l'assemblée et la buvette des députés en
fait partie est ce que les députés donne
un autre visage qui est le visage public
qu'on a deux dents dans l'hémicycle bien
sûr c'est plus détendu c'est
confidentiel voilà vous avez pas d'image
de la buvette normalement puisque les
photos sont interdites c'est un lieu
aussi de détente puisque vous avez une
petite terrasse et puis un lieu très
agréable imaginez c'est votre dernier
jour à l'assemblée
votre dernier verre à la buvette avec
est ce que vous le prendriez à je dirais
ugo bernalicis voilà qui est dit est de
la france insoumise oui oui oui qui est
un collègue qui est un bon copain qui
est un excellent parlementaire dans
l'hémicycle en particulier et sur les
sujets notamment de la commission des
lois
mais aussi quelqu'un avec qui on passe
de très bons moments à la buvette alors
c'est quelqu'un de très drôle et puis
avec une petite particularité c'est que
c'est lui qui a fait venir là une bière
pression qui s'appelle moulin d'ascq qui
est une bière artisanale bio la station
déception voilà qui est servi de
villeneuve d'ascq et qui est servi à la
buvette et elle est très bonne voie là
en 15 ans à l'assemblée vous avez aussi
vécu des moments émouvants je pense
notamment à la dernière question au
gouvernement de patrick roy alors il
était surnommé le député à la veste
rouge et c'était pour lui une question
en forme d'adieu à un moment où il
luttait contre un cancer s'était en 2011
regardez
donc ce combat contre la mort j'ai été
bouleversé
par le soutien de mes collègues de
gauche j'ai été autant bouleverser
autant bouleversé par le soutien tout
aussi humaniste du gouvernement de vous
monsieur le président alors que je vaux
vilipende à longueur de séances vous
avez été à mes côtés sans faille je vais
vous le redire c'est de vouloir dire je
vous aime toutes et tous la vie est
belle
c'était un moment très émouvant où elle
a vu assis juste derrière lui il ya une
larme patrick roy au début c'était un
collègue et puis c'est devenu un ami oui
tout à fait on était les montagnards
tout en haut là bas et c'est vrai que
patrick c'était mon voisin juste devant
moi
extrêmement turbulent comme vous le
savez est donc on le remarque est très
vite et il y avait beaucoup d images sur
patrick donc du coup moi j'en profitais
derrière et c'est vrai que quand on a
appris qu'il était malade qu'il avait un
cancer du pancréas à la fin de l'année
2010 avec jean mallot qui était aussi un
ses amis nous sommes allés le voir à
l'hôpital avec sa avec sa femme sa femme
que j'appelle tout où tous les ans les 3
mai pour les dates anniversaire de son
décès il est décédé le 3 mai 2011 et
bien j'ai une veste rouge de patrick roy
dans ma permanence parce qu'ils avaient
décidé d'en donner 3 une à jean mallot
une à son fils et est une qui est dans
mon bureau et donc chaque jour je pense
à lui il m'a beaucoup apporté moi j'ai
beaucoup appris en tout cas à son
contact on va parler de votre avenir à
présent
à quoi va ressembler votre vie après
l'assemblée d'abord j'ai envie
aujourd'hui après quinze ans au service
aujourd'hui du sport ici au parlement et
garder de me mettre aussi au service du
sport mais plutôt dans des fonctions de
conseil aux collectivités locales et aux
fédérations sportives aux grands
événements sportifs internationaux
aujourd'hui on a besoin de mener des
politiques publiques transversale
d'activité au physique de développement
des activités physiques à tous les âges
de la vie est bon c'est un domaine dans
lequel j'ai pu acquérir à une expertise
et je souhaite continuer à la porter
justement pour conclure si vous deviez
résumer ces quinze années passées à
l'assemblée en un titre de film est ce
que ce serait le dernier des mohicans
coup de tête ou un éléphant ça trompe
énormément
je dirais le dernier des mohicans ouais
bien sûr elle vous corresponde mieux ah
bon parce que j'ai été député génération
j'étais le seul député de mont mau
politique de benoît hamon pendant cette
dernière cette dernière législature le
seul le seul survivant le seul
qui a été réélu et puis je reste a aussi
un moyen quand du côté de la défense des
droits des parlements sur lequel je ne
transigerai jamais voilà je suis un
défenseur farouche de ce parlement jaime
l'assemblée nationale voilà j'ai dit
notamment à ceux qui vont être élus
vous allez faire un très très beau
mandat profitez-en spécialisé vous
faites du travail de contrôle
d'évaluation fait des rapports c'est
votre rôle vous avez un rôle extrêmement
important dans les institutions
françaises merci beaucoup régis juanico
d'être venu donc partager cette dernière
séance avec nous et puis bon vent pour
la suite merci beaucoup
m
[Musique]